Peter Tatchell welcome to chicken AMA
tree join you I'm Francis Foster I'm
constant and kissing and this is the
show for you if you're bored of people
arguing on the internet over subjects
they know nothing about trigonometry we
don't pretend to be the experts we ask
the experts here at the world-famous
angel comedy club our amazing guest this
week is one of the foremost human rights
campaigners of the last half-century
Peter Tatchell welcome to trigonometry
ready to join you let's start by asking
fundamentally the question that we
always want to know about is how did you
come to be the person that you are today
I heard you speaking about the fact that
one of the things that started your
human rights journey was finding out
about a man who was going to be hanged
in Australia
and he was hanged in fact despite the
fact that the evidence wasn't
particularly solid in that case and you
said that it kind of triggered in you a
suspicion of authority and I think
that's a feeling that lots of people
share for our generations probably the
Iraq war is a good example of something
that triggered this lack of faith in
figures of authority but not everybody
then goes on to have the life that
you've led which is being assaulted over
300 times a citizens two attempts to a
citizen's arrest on robbing Mugabe
confronting Mike Tyson of all people for
how using homophobic slurs not many
people have gone to risk their lives for
what they believe what was it about your
history your childhood perhaps that made
you into someone who was willing to
stand up for what you believed in the
way that you have I don't think there's
any one major event or influence but I
do know that growing up in the 1960s
watching the nightly television news
bulletins about the black civil rights
movement
was a very very influential factor
inspired me to first of all understand
about the horrendous racial segregation
and racist persecution of violence that
African Americans suffered but also gave
me an inkling an idea about how to do
Human Rights campaigning so in the last
half-century that I've been doing this
you know my model is nonviolent direct
action inspired by people like Martin
Luther King about so Mohandas Gandhi and
others I think their methods of peaceful
direct action and where appropriate some
of this obedience against unjust laws is
the model by which all successful
movements for social change have won
through but I'm curious about there will
be other there will have been other
people who have been watching Martin
Martin Luther King marching and and
seeing those movements who would not
have had the courage or whatever it is
that's driven you to risk your life and
limb essentially for what you believe in
what do you think it was that made you
prepared to do that to be willing to
risk your life essentially for that well
you're right I mean my school friends
also saw the same images but didn't act
I guess I've just got quite a strong
sense of right and wrong perhaps an
overdeveloped conscience I don't like to
see other people suffering you know I
love freedom equality justice I love
other people I put myself in their shoes
if it was me who was being persecuted or
unjustly treated I would want someone to
help me so when I see others suffering I
think well if I want others to help me
in that situation then surely I have
some responsibility to do something to
try and help them and were you always
like that were you like that as a kid if
you saw something something justice
happening as a ten-year-old would you
try to step in or defend
people who can yeah yeah and I don't
know exactly where it came from I
suppose it's partly from my very strict
quite fundamentalist Christian
upbringing my parents instilled me in a
very strong sense of you know follow
your own conscience don't just go along
with the mob
think for yourself stand up for what is
right even if it's unpopular and you
know from a religious point of view be a
good Samaritan you know don't walk by
another side of the street when someone
is is suffering so I guess that that was
part of the fact that impelled me to
take up these human rights causes I mean
there must be a part of you Peter though
that when you see and you get involved
in these struggles and one season
they're a part of your brain going I
mean we could have had it he's here if
we just would like other people did walk
on by is there a part of you that's like
that it was would you just not entertain
that that sense of doubt but I guess
when I see an injustice I'm aware that
I'm not the only person that's concerned
I mean there are other organizations and
individuals who also take up causes back
in the day you know millions of people
worldwide campaigned against apartheid
in South Africa
and supporting the internal struggle by
black South Africans and their white
allies they did eventually succeed in
overturning that horrendous racist
system so for me I've also had a very
clear understanding that it's collective
action that makes change I've done a few
things you know in a personal individual
way but mostly real change comes about
through lots of people getting together
and deciding that enough is enough so
that was the model of the Chartists
he fought for working-class votes in the
19th century it was the model for the
suffragettes who fought for votes woman
in the 20th century it was the model for
the campaign against the poll tax and
Margaret Thatcher's hated unjust unfair
attacks on local people it was through
collective effort that change was one so
I've always been part of a movement or
in support of a movement I don't think
that personally I've done much myself
but maybe I perhaps been a catalyst or a
voice or a platform for ideas and
movements that perhaps hadn't previously
received it and what I find fascinating
is is your is your desire well desires
probably the wrong word but the way you
quite literally put your body on the
line like and doing a citizen's arrest
on mcgaubey not once but twice I mean
what was that plan did you set out to do
that or did you see him and just me get
overtaken by a sense of injustice that
this man and what he was doing to him
Bob way but what happened was that
Zimbabwe and human rights defenders
asked me to try and do something to
highlife his human rights abuses at that
time in the late 1990s there was very
little media reportage about what was
happening inside Zimbabwe the arrests
and detention without trial the mass use
of torture the burning of houses and
crops a really quite gross tyrannical
regime which the world was pretty much
ignoring so the thinking behind the
attempt decisions arrests was firstly to
act on that request to support the right
it's involved with people who far more
than me were taking much much greater
risks to their lives and liberty but
through that process helping to shine a
spotlight on the gross human rights
abuses perpetrated by the mcGarvie
regime and I think that although I did
not succeed in arresting Mugabe even
though I had a perfectly lawful legal
case to have him arrested on charges of
torture because I had the evidence that
he had condoned acquiesced in the
torture people in Zimbabwe even I didn't
succeed those protests did help
highlight
though ments human rights abuses in
youth through dhikr the image of me
being beaten unconscious by his
bodyguards in Brussels in front of the
world's media in broad daylight I mean
most people have concluded if he's
prepared to have his minders beat up a
peaceful protester in the hard way
european capital city in broad daylight
in front of the world's media
just imagine what he's doing to his own
people when no one is watching so in
that sense it was very effective of
course I never wanted to or intended to
get beaten unconscious and I'm living
with the consequences with some brain
damage ever since but by comparison to
the suffering of human rights defenders
in t-bob we I've got off quite lightly
you know I know
activists in Zimbabwe who've been
detained for months even years without
charge who've been tortured and raped in
prison and some who have sadly been
killed by a central intelligence
organization they're Zimbabwean secret
police so pretty in that context of
perspective you know our baits and
sacrifices and taking some risk but
nothing nothing by comparison to the
risks taken by and the devastating
suffering endured by literally thousands
of human rights defenders in sites above
yourself did mcgaubey recognize you with
the second time when you tried to do a
citizen's arrest on him in the lobby of
the Hilton Hotel in Boston but my ploy
was I just walked into the middle of his
entourage but I was smiling and held up
my hand to shake his and of course that
led the security staff to lower their
guard because they thought I was a
well-wisher and I think initially so did
he
because he made half a smile and then he
suddenly had this heart of like ethical
candid camera well he was obviously as
you say very effective another example
of where this kind of attempt was
effective actually I find very
interesting hearing you talk about
confronting Mike Tyson where you
ambushed him and actually the way that
you told it essentially you were able to
reason with Mike Tyson and get him to
say to camera that he is not homophobic
can you tell us a little bit about that
story that I find that fascinating yeah
this was in Memphis Tennessee in the
United States just before he's world
title fight Lennox Lewis the Mike
Tyson's world title fight against Eric
Lewis you know I thought while he was
you know on record is making all these
homophobic slurs against Lennox Lewis in
previous against other boxers I thought
someone needs to change this and there's
also misogyny as well he was you know
the allegations or the conviction for
rape for which he served prison time and
you know his misogynistic slurs so I
wanted to do something and again it was
inspired by people in the United States
and some progressive liberal boxing fans
who said this is just this is just this
kind of behavior is not what sports
supposed to be about and they felt
particularly bad because Lex Lewis was
giving this non-stop tirade from Tyson
so anyway I went to United States to
Memphis I linked up with some local LGBT
activists and we made a calculated guess
about where he would be training we knew
where he was staying what we need we
knew the area where her stay we'd know
exactly we were staying and we knew
they'd have to go to
get a training session so we worked out
what was the nearest gym and laying
weight and our guests worked out to be
on spot-on and he turned up and he got
out of his SUV with always bodyguards
then I walked over to him and held the
placard you don't want to get a
lightweight like me doesn't want to get
a blow from Mike Tyson now No
so yeah I walked over 200 got out of his
van and said why are you making these
homophobic slurs get st. Louis and he
turned around with an angry face and he
lifted his fist oh oh no but then he saw
the TV cameras and he just relax for a
minute and then strep this rent you know
I'm not have a phobic I'm not homophobic
and I said well but you are saying
things that are homophobic and he said
well I said them I don't really meaning
I don't really mean them I was just
trying to wind up legs Lewis I said well
you wouldn't find it acceptable for
another boxer to wind you up using
racism why do you think it's acceptable
to use homophobia as a wind-up so going
from more defensive but eventually they
can point where I said to look if you're
not on the phobic will you make a
statement to the cameras saying that
you're against anti-gay discrimination
and sure enough he did and I can't think
of any other boxer or a world champion
boxers done that but so not at that time
anyway so yeah that was that was a win
you know here was Mike Tyson putting on
record that he opposed discrimination
against gay people was incredible
absolutely incredible and one of the
things I find fascinating about that
story is you were actually able to
reason with him in other words you were
able to talk to somebody who you
necessarily expect to be receptive to
that kind of communication and you were
able to convince him that what he was
doing was wrong
and to admit it on camera and to stop
doing it what do you make of the modern
social justice movement and how it seems
to be evolving where you've talked many
times about the fact that you think
freedom of speech is one of the most
important human rights and now it seems
like it's kind of falling down the
pecking order the people of being no
platform do yourself of you haven't been
quite no platformed I think but there
was a lady who refused to speak on the
same panel as you because you signed the
letter essentially saying freedom of
speech is important no platform is bad
it seems like freedom of speech is
falling down the pecking order what do
you make of that
I think it's certainly true that some
people nowadays take the stance well if
people are bigots or offensive they
don't have a right to speak you know
they should be barred from speaking they
should be shunned my view is they should
be challenged their ideas should be
countered there should be protest
against them but I don't think no
platforming is a way to make progress
because that doesn't make the idea go
away
it doesn't convince the person
supporters that I rethink is necessary
whereas if you engage in a dialogue
which sometimes may be quite unpleasant
but if you engage in a dialogue then
there's a chance that you can present
counter evidence to show why these
particular ideas are bigoted and wrong
so that's that's my approach I think
engagement is key and it's not just
about seeking to persuade the bigoted
because that may amount work what's
important about these public engagements
is that you engage with the wider public
who want that program or attend that
event so you're really doing teens two
things you're challenging the bigoted
person but you're also challenging those
ideas and speeding to are much wider and
perhaps more important audience do you
find it quite worrisome now at
that the term free speech is being
associated with the far right people
like Tommy Robinson or you know Katie
Hopkins as well and you know when they
and when they support free speech people
go you see this is why your free speech
advocates are wrong do you find that
quite worrying almost I certainly did as
somebody whose parents have come from
very well my mother is from Venezuela
where free speech is essentially
disappearing mmm yeah I think it is a
dangerous trend when people on the right
at least being perceived as supporting
free speech but of course they don't in
reality because they don't support free
speech for the victims their targeting
they want to shut them down bullying
them intimidate them and so on
so what's equally rude you know sad and
tragic is the way in which many on the
Left seem to now think as you say that
free speech is an expendable bourgeois
concept you know when it comes to you
know ideas that the left opposes just
ban them well that's got echoes of
Stalinism and you know you know Rosa
Luxemburg communist a german communist
in in 18th century she strongly disagree
with lemon she said that the right to
internal debate within the Bolshevik
Party and within the wider society is
absolutely paramount that you know there
has to be an opportunity for bad ideas
to be ventilated exposed and challenged
and that was very much an argument
against the sort of democratic
centralist party line that Lynne and
other leading Bolsheviks were advocating
they were saying that we will decide and
you all must support this that dissent
was tantamount to betrayal
and most of Octomom say no descent is a
vital component of an engaged evolving
political movement and that if a
movement isn't open to criticism and to
alternative points of view it's taught
sapphires and can often go badly wrong
as it course happened in the Stalin era
in particular so you would say that for
instance Tommy Robinson you do Nagri so
you think there's somebody like Tommy
Robinson should be allowed to speak he
should do you think it's put this
question in a more concise way do you
think it was wrong for someone like
Twitter to ban Tommie Robinson and to
remove his account or would you say that
ultimately he has a right and he should
be allowed to say what he thinks even if
you disagree with it or I disagree with
it because I strongly disagree with
Tommy Robertson and the movements he's
involved and associated with but my
understanding was that he was banned
from Twitter for simply making
criticisms of Islam they are criticisms
that I wouldn't make or not making that
way but I do think it's valid that all
ideas including religious ideas should
be open to criticism when it crosses the
line to abuse the insults when it
engages in threats menaces or harassment
and certainly if it involves any
elements of encouraging violence then
that is obviously clearly wrong to step
too far and that should not be tolerated
because it's not about that's not about
free speech that's a violation of free
speech because when you have that kind
of toxic atmosphere which Tommy Robinson
has often been associated with then
we're going to say you actually closed
down debate because the targets you know
Muslims immigrants refugees don't feel
able to speak out and engage in the
debate because they're intimidated they
fear the consequences so for you the
line on free speech is essentially I
mean you kind of put from what I took
out of that is you put insults and then
sigh them into violence into one
category where you are would you say you
should be allowed to
call someone names but you should
definitely not be allowed to incite
violence against them in a free society
yeah I think insults are okay but again
it depends on what kind of insult so
when it comes to free speech I've got
three red lines the first is I don't
think someone should be able to make
false damaging allegations against
another person for example to falsely
accuse them of being a pedophile or tax
fraud stur equally I don't think it's
right that a person should be able to
engage in threats menaces or harassment
and finally I think another red line is
incitements for encouragement to
violence and murder you know those are
criminal offences and quite rightly not
part of what constitutes free speech so
outside of those three red lines you
know I think people have a right to
speak but equally people have a right to
protest against that point of view I
think it's really important there is no
free pass given to people who promote
hatred and bigotry of course I mean
that's absolutely fascinating Peter one
question that I wanted to ask you I mean
do you think with the right of the
people right Trump who are openly
espousing racist views or racist points
of view
I mean brexit which I'm not saying that
everyone who voted breaks it is racing
of course that's absolutely wrong but
nevertheless there were certain
undercurrents to the brexit campaign do
you think we are regressing somewhat
with our with our tolerance in this
country and our levels of tolerance or
do you just think that you know with the
advent of social media that people more
and more people are able to contribute
their voice what social media is great
in there does give a platform a voice to
millions of people otherwise would not
have it that's a really positive element
but of course a lot of the interchanges
on social media are quite toxic
and actually break bad for people's
mental health and you know I'm not free
speech they are speech that's hateful
yeah often making fabricated allegations
so that to me is damaging and
undermining social media but where I
strongly disagree is with people who say
that's offensive you can't say that I
mean some of the most important ideas in
human history have caused great offence
in their time you think of Galileo
goalie Charles Darwin Sigmund Freud Karl
Marx
they all had ideas that many people
found deeply offensive and if this rule
that you can't cause offence applied
then those great people would have been
shut up and I don't think that's the
right way to go I think that that would
create a cultural stasis where new
radical dissenting ideas could be shut
down on the basis that some people found
them offensive and there's no part I'm
just curious because you know you've
spent you dedicate to your life to
fighting for these causes this is a part
of you that gets that's I mean you seem
like a very reasonable and gentle and
kind man but is there a part of you that
gets really pissed off when these people
are refusing to speak on a panel with
you calling you transphobic calling you
racist when you've been standing up for
the rights of ethnic minorities and LGBT
people your whole life it is their party
that goes how dare you but you know it
is half the course sadly you know you
just have to take the Brit bats and
carry on obviously you know you try to
counter them I try to counter them but
you know there is a tendency now among
sections of both the right and the left
among some people
to try and discredit other people by
smearing them as racist or a neocon you
know I think that's that's that's a way
to damage you rather than engage with
the arguments of the ideas rather than
look at the evidence you use the tactic
is to smear and slur and that's very
damaging for democracy because if that's
how democratic debate descends then
people cannot make decisions or come to
conclusions based on facts it's this
mishmash of fact fiction smear and
fabricate a lie and even the
conversation you had with Mike Tyson
would not have been possible if it just
been about labels you actually had the
conversation where it was productive
whereas if you just called each other
names that would not have happened
exactly yeah yeah and it was a really
good example of where he said something
offensive but rather than run away and
cry or rather than you know denounce him
I went engaged with him and got him to
make a positive pro-lgbt statement and
what do you make of this whole
collectivism that where people are now
trying to change the world as you've
tried to change the world but they're
doing it one Facebook post at a time one
campaign at a time while actually doing
something what do you make of that but I
think social media activism online
petitions they have a valid role but
they usually only effect if you could
get a hundred thousand plus signatures
or even several million I think a lot of
people do seem to think that picking the
mouth is I've done my bit yeah yeah and
you know thank you for clicking the
mouse and some of those mouse clicks do
have an impact but really an effective
campaign is much bigger and broader than
that it's got involved much more
interaction much more engagement and
that means a combination of protest
writing letters lobbies a whole host of
different things
well writing letters this is a very
British solution isn't incredibly
British solution to the problem oh
because it like no if someone gets a
letter you know they are more likely to
take it seriously than to get an email
does it matter about handwriting yeah
yeah we'll probably get even better
response but you know if all you could
do is type well okay do it this fireman
can go if you take nothing from this
podcast let's do this show please
remember if you want to protest against
something calligraphy is a way forward
write letters but you know really
effective campaigns like the campaign
against the poll tax in 1998 won because
yet people did sign petitions and write
letters but the real impetus for
Margaret Thatcher dropping that policy
was that millions of people either
refused to pay the poll tax or delayed
payment so the system became unworkable
so using that financial leverage proved
to be a very very effective way because
Thatcher ultimately realized even though
she said this was a flagship policy
there was no negotiation she wasn't for
turning when it came down to it so many
people made the poll tax unworkable that
she had to recant and I buy and abandon
it I mean one of the stories that blew
me away Peter from reading about your
career and I was actually talking to a
ghost rally and comment yes and I was
telling him stories about how you used
to at the very start of your career in
the seventies you used to go into
Australian bars where they they were you
know that they were openly homophobic
and engage in sit-ins and no that was in
London no sorry it was in London stop
smearing Australian apologies but no
just in bars in London which were open
and engaging sit-ins that to me
absolutely blows my mind I mean did you
ever would I mean you must have been
getting
to some incredible people during those
moments and were you genuinely fearing
for your life at certain points not with
the sit-ins no but yeah in the early
1970s it's true that there were some
bars restaurants pubs of our venues that
would not serve gay people so mom on the
black civil rights movement we decided
to organize sit-ins in those venues to
demand to be served and when we were
refused we sat down and refused to leave
and then of course the police were
called and we arrested but we didn't
have to do this for too long it was just
a matter of weeks really when most of
these venues eventually gave in because
we told them you know you can have us
arrested and carted out once twice three
times four times we're still going to
come back until you agree to serve gay
people and eventually most of those
landlords and managers realize that they
are on to a loser that we weren't going
to go away that in fact our repeated
sit-ins were actually driving away their
traditional customers so they were
losing money and of course money talks
and so eventually they gave in and
agreed to service so why did the Iraq
war campaign a fella I mentioned this at
the beginning that for our generation it
was a defining moment I certainly for me
it was a moment when for the first time
I realized even if millions and millions
of people around the world come out onto
the streets and protest about something
it's not gonna make the slightest bit of
difference and the Iraq war is been
something that's defined the the years
since I mean everything that's happened
has been what 15 years now Isis all of
the stuff we're still dealing with Syria
Iraq they're all consequences of that
war and despite the fact that millions
of British people and people around the
world came out onto the streets it just
went ahead why do you think that failed
I think we had in this country an
arrogant smug self-satisfied and
unresponsive government a made by Tony
Blair
and you know most you know democratic
governments do have a sensitivity
towards public opinion and when public
opinion is so overwhelmingly against an
action most governments and democracies
tend to you know withdraw revise their
policy but not Tony Blair the problem
was that we didn't have any leverage
other than the mass protests which he
was able to ignore you know in the case
of the poll tax campaign there was the
financial leverage of non-payment or
delay payment we didn't have an
equivalent if we had we might have got
the government to changes stance but we
didn't
so that war went ahead not only on the
basis of our lack of public support but
also of course based on a big lie
absolutely Peter just going back to the
issue of gay rights dude you must be
very very proud of everything you and
your supporters and activists of the
changes you've made for gay people over
the last 30 to 40 years it's a huge
achievement what would you see as the
next struggle for gay rights in order to
to achieve fairness and equality well
there are still some residues of
anti-gay prejudice like the fact that
half of all LGBT kids in schools are
bullied a third of all LGBT people in
the country have been victims of
homophobic biphobic or transphobic hate
crimes at least once and sometimes three
four or five times over their life so
you know the battle is not won yeah
we've got legal equality in most areas
public opinion has changed you know the
level of public homophobia is much less
than it was two or three decades ago but
globally that's where the real battle is
because still we have today 72 countries
where homosexuality is totally illegal
punch you up to life imprisonment in
some countries and facing the prospect
of even the death penalty in ten Muslim
majority countries that's definitely
something that to fight for what do you
make of you know I come from Russia as I
said what do you make of the situation
because you've been to Russia and you've
in fact do you think you've been
assaulted in Russia I welcome what do
you make of the situation there because
that's one country that seems to be
actually getting worse doesn't it yeah
although homosexuality was
decriminalized in the early 1990s under
Boris Yeltsin though there was a window
period where things seems beginning
better certainly in the Putin era things
have gone very much in Reverse yeah I
think Putin and his party have seen
homosexuality as a useful political
diversion you know LGBT people in Russia
are sort of portray effectively as the
enemy within which of course distracts
Russian people from the massive theft of
public assets by oligarchs the huge
corruption of Putin and other leading
Russian officials and the widespread
human rights abuses in that country so
it's a good diversion tactic in the same
way that or similar to the fact you know
that in the 1930s in Germany Jewish
people were used by the Nazis as a as a
as a way of deflecting German public's
attention from the crimes of the Nazis
in their own faith
so that that is definitely a backward
step and we have seen actually the
legislation passed in 2013 which
criminalized the so-called propagation
of homosexuality which in effect means
anything positive or informative about
gay issues falls within the criminal law
so people have been convicted under that
law for Hollywood placards saying
homosexuality is normal or just gay
rights you know ostensibly it's targeted
at protecting minors
well why do young people need protection
for security you know some of them will
be gay they need support and information
not not not the image or the impression
that it's something shameful wrong or
whatever but also of course you know
this is very much a product of the
alliance between the Putin regime and
the Russian Orthodox Church so we're
essentially in Russia today
[Music]
Putin supports the rational thoughts
Church and in return they support him
and the Russian Orthodox Church plus
some of the Muslim organizations also
have rallied very much to demand
crackdown homosexuality and they were
some of the prime movers behind the
legislation in 2013 so yeah things going
back with on top of that of course
you've got the rise of a social media in
Russia which is being exploited by
far-right extremists to target gay
people so far wide extremists will pose
as gay lure game into rendevouz and then
beat them up you know humiliate them by
shaping their head or pouring ink over
them a whole host of humiliations but
you know that is going on with
I wouldn't say state sanction but
certainly de facto state change section
you know there's no action being taken
by the Russian state to close down those
direct manipulations of social media to
perpetrate criminal acts of violence do
you ever find yourself Peter I mean you
come across as a wonderfully tolerant
man very very very gentle for want of a
better word do you ever find yourself
there getting frustrated and angered by
certain aspects of organized religion
which seemed to condoned homophobic
behavior and even encouraged it and
certain instances well I say that
organized religion is probably the
single greatest global threat to women's
rights and LGBT rights all over the
world where LGBT rights and women's
equality is under attack it is motivated
primarily by religious establishments
not necessarily people at the grassroots
of the faith but the religious leaders
so here in Britain we have the Church of
England the official established state
Church which opposes equal marriage it
says that gay people are inferior and
not entitled to the same right to marry
the person they love as heterosexual men
and women so that's you know an official
endorsement of legal discrimination by
the Church of England and the Archbishop
of Canterbury Justin Welby all over the
world everywhere from Russia to Uganda
Jamaica Iran Saudi Arabia it is
religious motivation that is
orchestrating the systemic persecution
of LGBT people and why do you think that
is I mean you must have some theories of
it why do you think that this is all
homophobic because I mean I was raised
as a Catholic my mother like I said
before his Latin American and Latin
American culture I mean he's deeply
homophobic I mean like for instance to
tell you a story my cousin
when I was very young in the early 90s
he passed away from an AIDS related
illness and he was a gay man and in that
time though he didn't bless him he
didn't no one who could admit that he
died of an AIDS related illness he died
of throat cancer because nobody wanted
to admit that he was going died of AIDS
why is it do you think that these
organizations are I'm a phobic because
to be honest with you I mean I'm
straight but it still makes me
incredibly angry
I think all the major faiths deeply
patriarchal you know very much based
upon male power and privilege and we see
that you know across the world most
faiths still have male only clergy you
know women are not allowed to be Imams
in Orthodox Islam it's only recently
that Judaism has opened up to women and
apart from the Church of England the
Episcopal Church in America and a few
others most Christian denominations are
overwhelmingly led by and ruled by men
and I think for a lot of men regardless
of faith a lot of men not so much in
this country now but log men
traditionally have been very threatened
and insecure about their own sexuality
and have therefore targeted other gay
and bisexual men this is what I was
gonna ask you it's a bit of a weird
question so please understand that it's
it's meant as a genuine curiosity
growing up in Russia I Russians
generally are very homophobic and I
heard all this stuff about how the
reason that people discriminate against
gay people is it's not natural that was
the thing that was said and one of the
things that actually if you look at the
facts homosexuality is prevalent in
animals in many animals as it is in
humans right do you have any idea of any
evolutionary theory that explains why
that is and the kind of evolutionary
rationale for homosexuality did you are
you aware of anything like that
I know that is the big conundrum because
of course Darwinian theory of evolution
talks about the survival of the fittest
and you know the reproductive capacity
is very much about survival right so why
would this set of factors combination of
genes and hormones and and social
factors why would it predispose every
known human society to have
homosexuality but to me that's an
interesting question it's not essential
no way we live our lives so I'd love to
know the answer to but what's really
important right now is to end the
persecution of LGBT plus people or
worldwide of course it is
[Music]
moving on to another topic I know you're
very passionate about electoral reform
in this country could you give just
explain to us a little bit about why
that is and the problems with our
current electoral system well just so
everyone knows I mean I am best renowned
for my work on LGBT rights but I've
always very consistently also campaigned
for other human rights as well and to me
one very important human right is the
right to vote in elections and for that
vote to count now in Britain no
governing party has won a majority of
the popular vote since 1931 Wow every
single UK governing party since 1931 has
come to power on a minority of the
popular vote mostly between 35 and 43
percent a clear minority so it means
that none of these governments has a
genuine popular mandate none can say
that we speak for the majority but of
course under our electoral system
repeatedly they're won a majority of
seats so Margaret Thatcher won a
landslide in 1983 but it was only based
upon 42% of the vote
Tony Blair won 55 percent of the seats
in 2005 but it was only based on 35
percent of the vote you know that
clearly is not democracy that's not what
the Chartists and the suffragettes
fought for you know they fought for our
representative Parliament and we don't
have one you know millions of people's
votes do not count you know it all
depends on marginal swings in marginal
constituencies
you know there's been elections where a
change of 15 to 20 thousand votes would
have changed the election result in
terms of seats won and governments
formed out of millions and millions of
votes it's swung on just 15 to 20
thousand votes in key marginals now that
is not a way to run a democracy that's
not a way to have a government that has
and inspires public confidence and that
encourages political parties actually
not to speak to the majority of the
people but to target very particular
constituencies very particular types of
people within those constituents
absolutely if you look at Cornwall for
example in the southwest of England less
than half of the voters voted
conservative yet they can service won
all the representation for the whole of
Cornwall I mean how can that be right
you know that's why we need a system
some system of proportional
representation like they have in
Scotland Northern Ireland and Wales and
in the London Assembly there it's not
perfect but there you do have a more
representative governance so for example
in London there's always been two or
three green members of the London
Assembly now the Greens never won any
seats in the constituencies based on
first-past-the-post but under the top
system they've won enough popular votes
to get them to seats and they have had
incredibly effective and out of all
proportion influence on policy in
government you know most of the major
innovative policies pursued by
successive London mayors were
initiatives that originally came from
the Greens
now I'm not saying that just because I'm
a Green Party supporter but I'm just
saying it's a good example of how when
you have a system of force
representation you do get a wider
spectrum of public opinion represented
and even if those are just minority
seats or minority representations they
can be highly effective and I can
actually make a very positive difference
to people's lives sure what the
interesting question there is the Lib
Dems if you remember at the time of the
coalition government they campaigned on
the referendum for some kind of they
couldn't quite get PR so they went for
some kind of P alternative vote yes
alternative vote should not be a and no
one really voted in that referendum and
it didn't go through and I think there
is no appetite in the general public
here in Britain for that system or
indeed it seems for PR I mean how do I
know public opinion is now very strongly
in favor of reforming the voting system
huh I mean it's probably not at the top
of people's agenda probably NHS and jobs
and shale education at the top but if
you ask people about you know should
Britain have a fair voting system does
the voting system need to change you
know clear majority say yes yes so why
hasn't it happened Peter because the big
two parties have a vested interest in
keeping the system the way it is because
they benefit from it you know Labour's
viewers will keep systems of ideas
eventually will win a majority and you
know we weren't actually bothered about
doing doing doing coalition's or
alliances with other parties but to me
you know I'm a very strong and very
sincere socialist I believe in quite
radical socialism but I only want to see
it happen if I can persuade a majority
of people that's the right thing to do I
don't want to sneak in socialism as a
result when unfair unjust on democratic
electoral system and I'm sad to say that
many people in labour want to exploit
the unfairness of the system so they can
get a majority and force through their
policies even if they don't have popular
support so we just have this tribal
political system and the two tribes are
warring and they don't want anyone else
to get in on their action so well here
we are the three of us here you are one
of the most prominent and effective
campaigners in recent history how do we
fix this how do we organize a campaign
for PR I'm down
you've got one supporter right how do we
do it well I have advocated for many
years that the campaigns for voting
reform should carry on with the tactics
they're currently using but also do
suffragette and charters style direct
action peaceful nonviolent direct action
to demand a fair voting system but sadly
those organizations are too timid no
they don't want to go down that road the
closest they've come to it is we did a
hunger strike for voting reform earlier
this year but you know a hunger strike
well okay it's it's it's it's a gesture
it's making a point that saying I feel
so strongly about this issue that I'm
prepared to go with that food and enjoy
the discomfort but it's not real
leverage yeah I think do we need a
citizen's arrest of Theresa May is that
we're saying possibly but I think we
need more than that we need a mass
movement I mean a mass movement that
like the suffragettes and the Chartists
is prepared to be challenging nonviolent
but but challenging is part of the
problem that it's not really a sexy
issue you know you're not gonna throw
yourself under a horse carriage over pie
it just doesn't so yeah you're right you
know most people think politics in terms
of issues that directly affect them and
their lives so you know taxation Social
Security benefits the NHS education
transport the environment these are the
meaty issues that proc you pie people
but we're never going to get those
issues right until we fix the voting
system that's the point I was gonna make
so how do we convince people to get on
board with that idea because I've been
thinking the P is a much better system
for four decades now really ever since I
discovered how the parliamentary system
and Britain works I mean it works right
it's better than certainly a lot of the
countries that we come from absolutely
but
that was necessarily healthy comparison
if you're trying to create a good
democracy how do you get ordinary people
to get that link that you've just
exposed there which is that if you want
to fix a lot of the social issues that
we keep talking about and a lot of the
practical issues we need a better
representative system how do you
convince ordinary people who look busy
lives I've got kids to bring up and
lifes to live and work to go to and
whatever to go ah
without this we don't have this how do
you convince ordinary people of that by
just as you as you put it you know mean
to explain and argue that unless we have
a fair voting system we're not going to
be able to address the issues that you
care about because a majority of people
in this country are broadly
left-of-center do support social
programs and public services but their
voice is not being heard in government
because the voting system keeps on
delivering governing parties with
minority support so when it comes to how
we move forward I think it's a
combination of education and persuasion
direct action and protests online
petitions it a whole host of different
things but in the day what is going to
convince people if they can see
understand that without PR the things
that they want to see happen won't
happen now give me an example if we'd
had a system of force representation in
Britain in the 1970s Margaret Thatcher
would have never been elected and she
would have never won those successive
election victories because every time
she did so based on a minority of the
popular vote only just over 40 percent
so for people on the left and central
politics who probably in most cases
loathe that
what it did to this country you've got
to ask yourself well you if you didn't
support PR that's why you ended up with
Thatcher and all the devastating
consequence so if you want to change
things and prevent a new Thatcher you
have to support a new voting system and
well I find very frustrating right now
is that labor is so far not supporting
our fair voting system you know they
want to keep things as they are they
were not benefit from the manipulation
of first-past-the-post that gave David
Cameron and Theresa May a victory
Margaret Thatcher a victory they weren't
a bit of the same system to give Jeremy
Corbyn a victory and to me there is no
socialism worth having unless it has
majority public support CPI I can see
why you never made it in politics
because your 40 principle principle
listen now we've got time for a couple
of questions one of the things when we
put out the fact that you were coming on
one of our viewers wanted to ask how do
you remain so hopeful because you must
be helpful to have lived a life that
you've lived how do you remain hopeful
in in the face of tragedy and horrors
and also just the kind of things that
we've just been talking about you know
the political political system that
ignores the voices of many many people
how do you maintain a sense of optimism
and hope when all of that is happening
well I guess I'm an unreconstructed
1960s idealist yeah I grew up in here of
great optimism about what could change
and how we could change it and I've seen
so many changes in my lifetime which of
course inspires me to keep campaigning
you know I think about terrible
injustice as such as the systemic legal
persecution of LGBT people in this
country which is now history and I with
many thousands of others was part of
that process of change and I think to
myself wow I helped do
something there's made life better for
vast numbers of LGBT people in Britain
yeah I look at the global stage and
and I've seen so many dictatorships fall
in my lifetime there were still
dictatorships and even new ones but you
know Franco is history Pinochet is
history
Marco's is history the old Soviet Union
is history
you know these are momentous changes
which should be brought about by
millions of people organizing to fight
for that change and so I just I feel
inspired by the changes that I'd be part
of and feel hopeful that further change
can come and I know that if we put our
minds to it we can change things not
always and will not always immediately
but but ultimately no too many last
forever
yeah out of Hitler promised to one
thousand year Reich it lasted all of 12
years there are many others in power
perhaps not direct tyrants but you know
people perpetrating great injustice they
won't last forever they will have their
day and be gone and that just keeps me
one piece want to fight on and help
bring about that change we have to end
up there than wait what a wonderfully
uplifting beautiful way to end the show
um thank you very much for coming on
Peter we always ask the final question
which is what is a one issue that you
think is incredibly important but people
aren't talking about nearly as much as
they should be do you think it's
obviously we've covered PR is there
something else says particularly dear to
your heart for me economic democracy is
the elephant in the room we live in
Britain and Western countries in an
economic detailer ship where the rich
and powerful have all the votes it's not
one person one vote in the economy
the directors the major shareholders the
managers they have all the votes and
ordinary people are excluded and
disenfranchised so when it comes to the
running of both private corporations and
public institutions like the National
Health Service they are run on quasi
authoritarian lines top-down but people
who work in those institutions have
little or no power and that strikes me
as being totally out of kilter with our
political system in politics we expect
democracy we expect one-person one-vote
we expect our rich person to have no
more boats than a poor person but that's
not translated into the economy so my
ask is if we expect political democracy
why not echo my democracy too why can't
we have a system for example where
private corporations and public
institutions would be required by law to
have say one-third employee
and consumer representatives on their
management boards with full rights to
information and full voting rights to
make it a more coke or partnership
between the people at the top and the
grassroots and you've got to remember
that the people who work in both private
and public institutions at the
grassroots they have a vast wealth of
practical knowledge about how those
institutions work how they could be
improved lots of things but their voices
and their contributions not being heard
so it's not only an issue of fairness
it's also an issue of making those
workplaces institutions operate more
effectively and efficiently so you know
I'd love to see you know the grass roots
porters nurses and doctors in the health
service have a direct input through an
electro presentative or more on the
managing board of their NHS trusts so
they could take to that major ball
practical ideas for about proving the
service and to have patient
representatives as well to give their
voice to say this is how the hospital
needs to change its operating system to
make it better for patients and for the
delivery of care now the German Works
model the German works council model is
an example of that I'd go it further but
it's a good example and I say that in
Germany
first of all employees feel they have a
stake in the company because they've got
representation on the works council
board secondly when they have a
grievance they take it to the board and
often it gets resolved that I'd have to
go on strike so you're not losing
production through strikes your
productivity is better the company's
operation is more efficient and
employees feel better involved and
rewarded because so often when those
issues are taken to the works council
there may be some resistance and some
are geology but in the end often is not
there'll be some compromise and the
workers in the end will make a game that
doesn't have an improvement
yeah we're too polarized but it should
and in the 1970s under the Labour
government of Jim Callaghan there was a
report produced by Lord Bullock which
proposed a very similar system sadly
sadly the left and the trade unions shut
it down they said this is corporatism
this is like no nobbling the unions
that's madness imagine if trade
unionists or employees had direct input
to the match of boards their companies
they could address their grievances in
the boardroom not on the picket line
they could take their message direct to
the people who had the power they have a
vote and they could perhaps persuade
some of the managers and shareholders to
vote with them so to me it is so obvious
that we need some system
of economic democracy it's good for the
economy it's good for fairness and
social justice there we go interesting
all right well Peter thank you so much
for coming on we really appreciate you
spending this time with us if you
enjoyed watching this episode do follow
us on YouTube subscribe to our channel
give us a rating on iTunes if you prefer
to listen follow us on at trigger pod on
Instagram and Twitter and we'll see you
in the week's time from now thank you
very much for tuning in thank you thank
you
[Music]